[Music]
thanks for being here you guys thanks
for having us
um you know it's the early hour of 10
o'clock P.M and we're just going to get
into this this whole thing about
blackberry and I'm going to start with
something really specific it's actually
for Glenn
Glenn how many takes did you have at the
pay phone because holy shit man that was
crazy not bad
uh one oh the destruction of that phone
was I mean it looked like you got it one
and done it looked really good I think
we I think we only had one phone uh it
wasn't it wasn't even in the script do
you remember how that came about I
remember it vividly okay because I I
don't it's a little blur I'll tell you
exactly what happened I said we were on
the very first take we brought this
phone booth in we were like so stoked it
looked so beautiful Jared our
cinematographer was like okay I got this
looking great how many takes you want to
do and I was like I don't know let me
talk to Glenn and I said Glenn maybe
we'll shoot a couple and then maybe on
one of them I don't know if you want
just like hit it really hard maybe maybe
just try to break it he was like you
kidding me this phone booth I'll break
this thing in one hit and because he'd
said that and then we rolled the tank
and he hit it and the first time it
didn't break he went off and so that was
the first take and you see Glenn just
kind of it's very in very Jim balsley
way he was like well I'm not going to be
wrong
I'm not going to let this phone booth
beat me I'm not like I said I'm gonna
break it and so now I really have to
fucking break this thing and it's one of
those beautiful moments when you're
making a film where because you've got a
kind of relationship with your actor it
creates a moment of drama that you could
never you couldn't plan that because you
were doing it with an what you almost
call it like an of the moment energy you
guys hear that there's white noise holy
shit is that deliberate are we getting
that pipe down Mike Mike is gonna have
to fixing poison gas
slowly
that okay stop thank God it's not
someone put a paper clip in whatever was
making
that noise yeah
um Matt tell us a little bit about now
you just mentioned him and I want to
talk about a couple of the collaborators
that you have worked with throughout
your career
um let's talk first about Jared uh who's
behind the cinematography and I know
that you've worked with him at least
it's got to be 10 years now it's 20 23.
thinking back to the dirty The Dirties
which and even earlier than that because
I made a web series in Toronto what I
that I shot with him I love working with
Jared because he's so intuitive in all
my films I'm trying to capture the same
thing which is a feeling of you the
audience getting to enter the mind of an
operator and see what they think is
interesting and it's why I love working
with Comedians and especially with these
two because we didn't really rehearse
much and what it meant is that the
camera is discovering what's happening
as it's happening like you don't know
where Jay's gonna go you don't know
where Glenn's gonna go and if you've got
somebody who is intuitive and cares and
is listening then that eye that camera
winds up telling you a story of interest
and for me I'm not sure if it translates
to audiences but I love feeling like I'm
discovering what these guys are going to
do were those kinds of detail I mean
obviously when we could do Applause for
everyone art Department light I mean
it's like my wife is here Jen thank you
for this you just put this in my brain
to put us in that world in that time
96.030708
I mean I'm aging myself here it doesn't
feel like that long ago to me and
probably a lot of us but it's not the
world we live in now not at all so to
make that happen how does that affect
your performances as actors now I mean
obviously hair and makeup yeah costuming
but then you're in that world and you're
dealing with these references with with
your director does that inform your
choices that inform what you're doing on
set
yeah big time it's kind of like it ends
up having a bit of a
Truman Show effect because it's like
um the way that they operate the way
that they shoot we often didn't know
where the camera was and we didn't and
often didn't know if we were on camera
so so
we so as a result so that meant that all
our sets had to work 360 degrees right
and so like there was no giveaway
there's not like when you're on like a
stage and you look up and you just see
all this fucking scaffolding you're like
oh I'm not in a kid's bedroom or
whatever you know not that I'm ever in a
kid's bedroom but uh but but you know
when he played a kid when he played a
kid it was the 90s it came out fucking
awful
um it's been a long day kids no no more
kids talking about this movie since 8 30
a.m but uh um but but no so so they just
built with like Reckless abandon and
like exteriors fucking too like that
scene that shot of us like pulling up in
the beginning after our bad pitch and
just walking you know with forgetting
the easel walking from the car just to
the office like that entire Plaza is
like decked out in old 90s Canadian
Brands and I was like how the fuck did
you find this shit and then like at Rim
two all all of those details not just
the posters but the like Ninja Turtles
blam hanging from the ceiling and all
this stuff that I found out was
literally just from Matt's house uh um
but but like but it's like it's all real
none of it was ever assumed I don't know
what you call it but there's this weird
type gibberish that they use in movies
when you have to read a newspaper and
he's like as long as it's not in a
close-up because it'll just say a bunch
of Latin nonsense or or or nothing
there was none of this everything
everything was handled with the exact
same degree of care that the screenplay
was and the filmmaking was and to him it
was all part of it and it's impossible
not to be inspired by it
yeah I mean yes every response gets
Applause thank you don't forget the rule
and and Glenn listen one thing we
haven't talked about yet is that of
course this story is adapted from a book
right that was uh losing the signal
right for you in particular I mean
obviously there is
um let's just say a deep and consistent
intensity uh to uh the characters yeah
just a bit that you play
were you you were resources did they
include the book did you have any
conversations with the real man who you
were depicting in the film or was this
all just in the creative team or kind of
in your own mind that you brought that
you brought your performance I mean most
of it was really just informed by the
script I mean I did I did as much
research as I had time to do uh as one
does but I also was leaning on the fact
that Matt and Matt and his writing
partner Matt Miller and producer
um had also done research that went far
beyond the book um and speaking to
employees ex-employees of the company
and so I knew that they were approaching
it uh you know knowing the having the
inside scoop so
I really focused most of my attention on
on the character that I was interpreting
from the from the script yeah now that
makes a ton of sense and and obviously
these these two guys Jay and Glenn
they're they're so different there's
they're on opposite sides I mean Matt
the opening shots even right these these
two guys are going to the same place we
watch you pass horses I mean we're
talking about like I'm thinking about
metaphors about technology and human
history and where are we going in the
future yeah and it's it's all there for
us if we want it
how did you two interact when you were
not in a take I mean obviously you you
guys have comedy backgrounds you affable
dudes good normal guys other than the
kids I mean other than that one thing
yeah I shouldn't have said that nope I
could have said that's in the trades
tomorrow department store the dining
room yep I'll be thinking about that one
for a while
no we got on like a house on fire man it
was like you know it's it is an
inherently ridiculous proposition to
like dress up to pretend to be somebody
else
that's not a normal thing to do and so
when you were like hanging out with
somebody was like yeah this is fun but
this is insane like what the fuck is
this you know you just kind of I don't
know we we also been at it uh they're
the same amount of time you know and uh
and so and we just knew people in common
had experiences in common and shit and
so like yeah I don't know Glenn and I
got on super good yeah it was really fun
I mean I I was I was a little bit
more isolated on the whole I would say
you know there wasn't uh there weren't
there weren't people in the film that I
have tremendous camaraderie with
so uh I I think rousing endorsement so
and I mean I I mean the characters I
don't mean the other actors they were
everybody was wonderful but um
you know I think
you know I I don't do like you know
method actory type stuff but I but I do
think that like
uh I mean I I I I in some ways I did
kind of keep to myself a little bit and
and kept myself separated
um it just
felt weird to try and you know just be
my usual Happy jovial jokey self all the
time and then try to you know jump into
that kind of level of intensity and
seriousness
um so I I was probably less affable on
this set than than I'd like to think
that I that I usually am I thought we
had a nice time nobody
yeah when it was when
no I'm usually way funnier than that
now you really
season and stuff a bunch anyway it was
all bullshit Jay I'm sorry he was just
trying to make you feel better yeah
I get it
Matt okay so I was gonna say for the
record these guys never hung out with me
okay like never talk to me
I'm just kidding I'll tell you one thing
that is really true about what Glenn's
because Glenn's being modest I I think
that he did us a huge favor in his the
way he composed himself on set and I'll
tell you why it it was very clear to me
early on when we're making this film
that it is a story about a kind of
hacker group of young people who don't
really know how the world works
getting
forced into a new place by a very
experienced driven ambitious man and it
was essential that at no point in the
movie did they infect him with what they
cared about and vice versa and by Glenn
approaching the shooting of this movie
with the seriousness that he did it made
it so real for those other guys because
I don't know if the other Engineers who
are in this movie are not actors those
are just either students or friends of
mine two filmmakers a musician they're
they're filmmakers from Toronto and uh
and they're they're never acted before
really
um and I and I wanted that so that it
could feel like
all that dialogue is improvised I wanted
to feel well for lack of a better word
like real or tangible and then to have
somebody with the presence of Glenn walk
into that room with a bunch of
essentially kids who are very
intimidated by somebody like this but
then on top of that he is not in between
takes being like Oh hey guys uh we're
all best friends don't worry that was a
huge service that you did for us because
it created a culture that made the
difference between action and cut almost
you could you couldn't tell when it was
and it was kinetic when you were there
versus when you weren't because
everybody could really relax in
character and then I think you've heard
this before when you would show it
people would be like this
they would sit up in their chair and be
like okay Glenn's here oh wait Jim's
here like oh like we need to now we have
to stop acting like stupid kids and that
was either was hugely powerful because
in some ways that is one of the things
that the movie is about yeah well thank
you I I mean yeah I I did get the sense
that some people were a little like
scared of me at times you spoiled the
land party
uh uh and I and I I leaned into it a
little bit it helped it helped and then
what was so beautiful and Glenn talked
to me about this before but we wrapped
okay so the movie ends at obviously a
certain point and afterwards he would go
he was going around just shaking
everybody's hands saying hi to everybody
and the most common refrain he got from
people from the crew is oh I've never
seen you smile yeah
that's true yeah so I turned into a
completely different person to yourself
I actually felt it happen it wasn't an
intentional thing but the minute we
wrapped I just I dropped all of it
although all of Jim just just your hair
came back
instantly uh and and and and and and I
really really it was it was like I I
wasn't registering the fact that what I
was presenting to people in that moment
was totally different was a totally
different person than the person they
had been filming with for the last two
months but to me I was like oh no this
is who I really am like I'm you know
what I mean I'm not I'm not I'm not a
scary asshole uh you know uh but then I
saw people's reactions and I was like oh
right oh I'm not okay I see what's
happening here they haven't met this
person they haven't they actually hadn't
met me yet exactly yeah I'm just
imagining the the now what we can now
confirm is very real fear of the cats
subsiding after a take with Glenn and
then that cast being potentially even
more afraid because they have to deal
with Michael Ironside so holy crap but
they're afraid for different reasons
yeah so but really quickly and we have a
few more minutes can you tell us about
some of the other Great Canadian actors
that are in this cast solve rubinek
Michael Ironside how did they get
involved what was it like to have them
on set as well I had I had a vision
early on where I was like I want as many
actors in This film to evoke the same
feeling of the Blackberry which is oh I
remember him oh I didn't know they were
Canadian right
[Laughter]
right I felt like it was going to work
at the component level the metaphor no
matter how many layers you took it up
and and both Michael Ironside and Saul
rubinek are these like classic character
actors I mean Ironside was Paul
verhoven's boy and from his own mouth
you know I was supposed to play RoboCop
but the suit didn't fit
and he he brought when I watched yeah
yeah okay
um it those guys came and I mean it was
probably more you guys probably felt it
more than I did because it was like and
the more professionals that were on the
set the better but on those days when it
was like those scenes with Saul
specifically where you guys were
pitching I just it was a movie movie
where I was just watching you guys play
fucking Command and Conquer for like an
hour and a half I was like bro we got
eight pages to shoot you know like
um but we needed him just a little
sliver sometimes you gotta shoot a lot
for that though we're spoiled for riches
with with our cash every single Donovan
Mark critch like we we had a bunch of
like spectacular actors and um yeah I
think that's kind of like one of one one
of the wonderful kind of ways that the
movie functions is as this neat little
Advent calendar because they they each
occupy their own little space and you go
in there and you're in a room with them
and then that's just this this beautiful
little sequence and you go on to another
one and so like yeah I love our Ensemble
yeah it was I mean I think we all agree
you can see how many folks have stayed
here it's a really fantastic job that
you guys have all thank you and uh let's
give one more round of applause thank
you for Jay Glenn and Matt thank you so
much thank you all for coming check out
filmindependent.org for more film
independent presents events and we'll
see you next time thank you so much
[Music]
foreign